4.6 billion years ago hundreds of infant
planets begin to form around the new Sun
among them the baby Venus and Earth and
as they hurtle around the Sun collisions
are inevitable
planet formation is like a demolition
derby in a derby the cars are racing
around a track going around in circles
at different speeds well it's the same
thing with planets the material is
orbiting the Sun it's going around and
they're all going at different speeds at
different angles different trajectories
and sometimes
in this Derby planet its planet to
become one
violently
you have these large bodies that are
hitting each other a really high
velocity
it's really very hot violent mess the
amount of energy releasing these impacts
is huge it completely Dwarfs all of the
nuclear weapons on earth combined and
yet somehow on these scales you wind up
forming gigantic objects that we call
planets Earth and Venus become voracious
Planet eaters but two spectacular
collisions set the twins on very
different paths that was the moment
Venus and Earth went through this
divergence to what has now become these
really dramatically different worlds the
divergence begins when a mars-sized
object hits earth
the impact makes our planets spin faster
the core spins with it
generating a powerful magnetic field
around the planet
the field fends off the worst of the
sun's radiation around the same time
Venus takes a head-on hit from another
infant planet this impact explains
something very weird about Venus Venus
is actually rotating in the wrong
direction how could that be well what if
it got hit really hard by some object
that could do it an object so huge
Venus stops in its tracks and begins to
spin backwards if you think about how
much energy and what size you need to
change a planet spin that is an
incredibly large hit
but the backspin is slow 243 times
slower than Earth without a fast spin
Venus's core can't generate a strong
magnetic field it has no protection from
the deadly stream of particles blasted
from the Sun Venus does not have a
strong magnetic field and so it has
suffered the full brunt of this wind
blasted out from the Sun the tale of two
planets now splits radically Venus will
roast under a violent suffocating
atmosphere earth will give birth to
oceans life and intelligence
but ultimately these twins fates are the
same Earth's future is Venus pure hell
you